one thing everyone's been talking about
the last couple days is Brett Kavanaugh
high school yearbook everybody's talking
about this there it is many of the
entries next to Cavanaugh is picture
upset people and they caused him a lot
of embarrassment we're told so
embarrassment you should talk yeah I saw
your high school yearbook when did when
did you see my yearbook well there's a
copy in your office I grabbed it when
you weren't around I I thought it might
be fun to share it with everyone no no
you don't know check out check out some
of these clubs take a look the can't
swim team the staying inside Club the
shout out to my friends Herman and
Edmund we would have pounded down that
tab soda together we can find Waldo
faster Club when we heard boof we think
of John Wilkes Club Friday nights with
Bam Bam weeds and my other stuffed
animals the president of the never used
the school bathroom club I was on that
too and finally hot weekends with my
girlfriend from Canada who is definitely
real
you
you